Добрий день. Сьогодні ми продовжуємо
вивчати оксигеновмісні органічні сполуки.
Сьогодні ми з вами ознайомимося із жирами,
їхнім складом, фізичним властивостями.
Дізнаємося, що таке
природний і синтетичний жир
та поговоримо про біологічну роль жирів.
Перед тим, як перейти до вивчення нової
теми, давайте перевіримо домашнє завдання.
Вдома вам треба було
розв’язати таку нескладну задачу.
Розв’язок.
Розв’язання.
Для того, щоб розв’язати
цю задачу, треба пригадати,
що таке масова
частка речовини у суміші.
Мило – це суміш, а речовини –
це вищі карбонові кислоти.
Масова частка вищих карбонових кислот –
це відношення маси кислот до маси мила.
Із цієї формули ми
можемо знайти масу кислот.
Маса кислот – це добуток масової
частки кислот на масу мила.
0,72 – це масова частка,
200 гр. – маса мила.
Отже, маса вищих карбонових кислот,
які містяться в цій масі мила –
144 гр.
Відповідь: маса кислот – 144 гр.
Переходимо до вивчення нової теми.
Що таке жири?
Жири - це похідні триатомного спирту
гліцеролу і вищих карбонових кислот.
Зараз на слайді представлено
загальну формулу жиру
і отакий рисунок, який
відображає молекули жирів.
Давайте спробуємо
з’ясувати, що таке похідні
триатомного спирту гліцеролу
і вищих карбонових кислот.
Триатомний спирт гліцерол –
це багатоатомний спирт.
До складу спирту входять
три гідроксильних групи.
Карбонові кислоти.
Карбонові кислоти
містять карбоксильну групу.
Ми можемо записати або через
карбонільну і гідроксильну, або СООН.
І так правильно, і так.
На минулому уроці ми з вами ознайомилися
з трьома представниками
вищих карбонових кислот –
пальмітиновою, стеариновою та олеїновою.
Пальмітинова і стеаринова кислоти – це
представники вищих насичених кислот.
Олеїнова кислота – представник
вищих ненасичених кислот.
Я нагадаю, ці кислоти
відрізняються тим, що
у вуглеводневому заміснику
олеїнової кислоти між 9 і 1О
атомом Карбону є подвійний зв'язок.
Це впливає на властивості кислоти і жиру,
який утворений цією кислотою.
Уперше синтез жиру здійснив
французький учений М.Бертло у 1854 році.
Бертло в лабораторних
умовах синтезував жир.
Він добув його із гліцеролу
і вищої карбонової кислоти.
Цим синтезом Бертло довів,
що органічні сполуки можна
добути в лабораторних умовах.
Хоча до цього вважали, що
такі сполуки можна добути
лише із клітин живих організмів.
Отже, давайте спробуємо з’ясувати,
як відбувається реакція утворення жиру.
Вихідні речовини – гліцерол
і вищі карбонові кислоти.
Для прикладу я взяла
різні карбонові кислоти.
Це вказано замісниками:
замісники R1, R2, R3
різні – різні кислоти.
Тобто, до складу жиру
можуть входити різні кислоти.
Як відбувається реакція?
У молекулі гліцеролу із гідроксогрупи
відщеплюються атоми Гідрогену,
а від молекул вищих карбонових кислот
із карбоксильної групи
відщеплюються гідроксогрупи.
Залишки сполучаються і утворюється жир.
Крім цього, виділяється вода.
Зверніть увагу!
На слайді є малюнок.
На цьому малюнку показано
форму молекул жирів.
Перший і другий малюнок.
На першому малюнку показано рисунок жиру,
який утворений вищими
насиченими карбоновими кислотами.
Якщо кислоти насичені,
то оцей вуглеводневий замісник
дуже щільно упаковується
один відносно одного.
Якщо ми говоримо про жири,
які утворені ненасиченими
карбоновими кислотами,
то у зв'язку з тим, що може бути
подвійний зв'язок між атомами в заміснику,
такого щільного упакування немає.
Це впливає на фізичні властивості.
Жири, які утворені
вищими ненасиченими карбоновими кислотами,
мають температуру плавлення нижчу
за температуру плавлення жирів,
які утворені вищими насиченими
карбоновими кислотами.
Класифікація жирів.
Класифікація жирів за походженням:
жири можуть бути тваринного походження.
Наприклад, добре відоме вам
свиняче сало і вершкове масло.
Я думаю, кожен із вас
знає ці продукти харчування.
До речі, українська національна
кухня має низку особливостей.
Однією з цих особливостей є
широке вживання свинини і сала.
Українці вживають сало
як самостійну страву,
а можуть використовувати його як
основу для приготування інших страв.
Давайте пригадаємо українське прислів’я:
«Без хліба – не обід, без сала – не борщ».
Отаке ставлення
українців до свинини і сала
споріднює українську національну кухню із
західнослов’янською, угорською,
білоруською і російською кухнями.
За походженням жири ще можуть
бути рослинного походження.
Жири рослинного
походження називають «олія».
Наприклад, соняшникова олія,
кукурудзяна олія, оливкова олія.
Зазвичай, жири тваринного
походження – тверді, а рослинного – рідкі.
Втім, не можна сказати, що
жири тваринного або рослинного походження
утворені якимось певними
вищими карбоновими кислотами.
До складу жирів і тваринного,
і рослинного походження
входять залишки вищих і насичених,
і ненасичених карбонових кислот.
Серед жирів тваринного походження
є рідкі жири, наприклад, риб’ячий жир,
а серед жирів рослинного походження є
твердий жир – наприклад, кокосова олія.
Властивості жирів.
1. Жири можуть окиснюватися.
Внаслідок повного окиснення жиру
утворюється вуглекислий газ і вода.
Чому так? Тому що до складу жиру входять
елементи: Карбон, Гідроген і Оксиген.
Тому і утворюється вуглекислий газ і вода.
Ця реакція є реакцією екзотермічною.
Це зазначено в рівнянні:
дельта Н менше нуля.
Реакція відбувається з виділенням теплоти.
2. Лужний гідроліз (омилення).
Давайте спробуємо з’ясувати,
що таке лужний гідроліз.
Жир, утворений гліцеролом
і стеариновою кислотою (тристеарин)
і розчин лугу (Натрій гідроксиду).
Внаслідок цієї реакції
утворюється гліцерол
і сіль стеаринової
кислоти (Натрій стеарат).
Ми на минулому уроці з
вами говорили про те, що
солі вищих карбонових кислот – це є мила.
Тобто, Натрій стеарат – це мило.
Внаслідок реакції утворилося мило,
тому реакція називається «омилення».
3. Гідрування.
Гідрування – це приєднання водню.
Коли ви вивчали ненасичені вуглеводні,
там ви говорили про такі реакції.
Гідрування – це приєднання водню.
Які жири можуть приєднувати водень?
Якщо до складу жиру
входить вуглеводневий замісник
ненасиченої карбонової кислоти,
то такий замісник може приєднати водень.
Якщо ми говоримо саме про
залишок олеїнової кислоти,
яка містить подвійний зв'язок
між 9 і 1О атомами Карбону,
то кожен ось такий замісник може
приєднати одну молекулу водню.
Тобто, на 1 моль жиру треба 3 моль водню.
Внаслідок цієї реакції
утворюється речовина,
яка містить залишки
насичених карбонових кислот.
Тобто, що ми бачимо?
Рідкий жир
перетворюється на твердий жир.
Рідкий жир (олія) – природний,
в результаті приєднання водню
утворюється синтетичний жир.
Речовина, яка утворилася, є
основою для добування маргарину.
Біологічне значення жирів.
Жири це джерело енергії.
Внаслідок повного окиснення 1 гр. жиру
виділяється енергії вдвічі більше,
ніж внаслідок окиснення
такої самої маси вуглеводів.
Жири входять до складу клітин і
слугують для них джерелом енергії.
Жири є носіями життєво
необхідних речовин для організму.
Жири виконують теплоізоляційну
функцію - вони захищають
глибоко розміщені тканини від
надмірного впливу тепла або холоду.
Виконують амортизаційну функцію -
забезпечують захист кісток,
тканин і внутрішніх органів від ударів.
Якщо з їжею поступає менше жирів, то
це впливає на діяльність ЦНС та імунітет.
Більш докладно із
біологічним значенням жирів
ви будете знайомитися на уроках біології.
Давайте зробимо висновки.
Жири - це продукти взаємодії триатомного
спирту гліцеролу
і вищих карбонових кислот,
як насичених, так і ненасичених.
Жири не розчиняються у воді,
на повітрі повільно окиснюються.
Рідки жири можна перетворити
на тверді реакцією гідрування.
Гідрування – це приєднання водню.
Жири - біологчно активні речовини,
мають високу енергетичну цінність
і є невід'ємною складовою
нашого харчування.
Давайте розв’яжемо завдання до уроку.
Ми з вами сьогодні
вивчили, що жири – це похідні
триатомного спирту гліцеролу
і вищих карбонових кислот.
У цьому випадку нам потрібно
написати формулу жиру,
який утворений гліцеролом
і пальмітиновою кислотою.
Залишок гліцеролу…
Тепер приєднуємо залишки
від пальмітинової кислоти:
карбонільна група
і вуглеводневий замісник.
Пальмітинова кислота у
вуглеводневому заміснику
містить 15 атомів Карбону
і 31 атом Гідрогену.
Так само дописуємо і далі…
Карбонільна група і
вуглеводневий замісник.
Це – формула жиру, який утворений
гліцеролом і пальмітиновою кислотою.
Наступне – Б.
Аналогічне завдання:
треба записати формулу жиру, який
утворений залишками олеїнової кислоти.
Знову починаємо із залишку гліцеролу.
Олеїнова кислота – це ненасичена кислота,
яка у вуглеводневому заміснику
містить 17 атомів Карбону
і 33 атоми Гідрогену.
Це ми з вами зобразили формулу жиру,
який утворений гліцеролом і
залишком олеїнової кислоти.
Домашнє завдання.
Перше завдання.
Складіть рівняння реакції горіння
жиру, похідного стеаринової кислоти.
Для того, щоб виконати це завдання,
я вам раджу спочатку
зобразити формулу жиру, як
ми це робили зараз на уроці,
потім – записати молекулярну
формулу цього жиру,
а потім вже писати рівняння реакції
повного окиснення, тобто, горіння.
Друге завдання.
На цьому наш урок закінчено.
Я бажаю вам всього найкращого!
Друзі, привіт!
Пропоную вам сьогодні трохи потанцювати.
У нас в гостях сьогодні Dj Nana.
- Всім привіт!
- Ви готові потанцювати з нами? – Так!
Супер! Давайте розпочинати!
В інший бік.
Фінальний рух.
- Мені здається, чи вже дзвоник?
- Так!
Вже закінчилася наша
драйвова руханка. Давайте п’ять!
Ви дуже крута!
Дякую, друзі! Сподіваюся,
вам теж сподобалося.
До зустрічі!